If I had one piece of advice
for my 16-year-old self,
it would probably be
to go out and see the world at that age.
I didn't leave the United States
until I was 22 for the first time,
and, you know, I'd already been working
and starting to develop my career.
It wasn't until I left
and I could see the world sort of as a whole
that I really could get a sense
for where my place in it was
and what I wanted to do
because, you know, you grow up
and you're sort of in this narrow bubble
and it's very easy to stay in that bubble
and to get stuck in that bubble.
And I think it's very important
to expand the ideas that reach your mind
and the people that you meet
because it really helps you develop
who you want to be as you get older,
so that's what I would tell myself
when I, if I could, when I was 16.
I would say go out and see the world
as soon as possible.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.